energy is the one thing that we have a
finite amount of
and where we direct that energy are we
getting a return on that energy is that
energy impactful if we're thinking about
the same thing we have a problem we're
thinking about it you know our brain
loves habits that loves patterns it
loves
processing things but it can be very
efficient inefficient because the
emotions get involved when our emotions
get involved we tend to kind of recycle
the same thought time and time again
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctek
to 20 minute leaders this is a very
special episode really all about
leadership in very very unique ways
meet vivian james rigney president and
ceo of incitus llc a global executive
coaching consultancy operating
throughout five continents where he has
helped implement leadership development
initiatives for some of the world's
leading companies and their executive
teams he has also climbed the seven
summits the highest peak on all seven
continents on march 8 his book naked at
the knife edge was published a book
about its climbing of everest and an
epic story of fear resilience and the
power of vulnerability
i'm really excited to talk to you about
leadership as simple and as complex as
it may be um you know having climbed the
seven summits uh and uh with an amazing
book coming out and i believe just
recently given when this publication is
so it will act as if it has already come
out and talking about that adversity and
talking about defeating defeating
challenges all in the context also of
leadership and you as a professional
coach
and and running some you know helping
phenomenal ceos and phenomenal
organizations become their best leaders
that they can be in the president of
inside us so so vivian over these 20
minutes i'm excited to tap into your
stories of climbing the seven summits
you as a coach understanding better for
myself as a young entrepreneur what does
it mean to be a good leader in your eyes
thank you so much for coming
yeah i think the
the core and the premise of the book is
that um climbing everest is a metaphor
for how to overcome challenges but but
the most important thing to be an
effective leader and there are obviously
lots of leadership books on how to lead
how to influence people how to have
impact and all those very important
things but it really starts with
yourself
and that level of self-awareness one has
to be aware of yourself one has to make
peace with yourself one has to
understand
how to disarm the ego
how to uh be very aware of a persona
that is unhealthy so an ego that's
unhealthy personas unhealthy again
coming back to the core coming back to
yourself and that's the premise of the
book is based on on on and that's the
starting point when we are in a good
place with ourselves
then we can help other people then we
can impact other people then we can be
aware of other people we can understand
what's happening around us
um and a lot of people i work with very
smart very talented seasoned experienced
very dynamic lots of ideas great energy
um but a lot of them can overthink
and when they overthink they're burning
an extra inordinate amount of energy
and um
that's energy that that could be used
elsewhere and this this idea of um
clarity in their mind
are reducing the inner inner dialogue in
their mind and allowing them to much
more intuitive much more aware of what's
happening around them and at the same
time being authentic so that coming from
an authentic place from a genuine
authentic place and in doing that you
have to be at peace with yourself you
have to have that inner inner you have
to be that inner rock and for and this
if we think of the corporate world and
we think of it also with um with sports
you know if you're an athlete if you're
in the olympics
you know coaches are training people to
get out of their heads to get what they
call in the zone and in business and
corporate nowadays we're hearing much
more about mindfulness much more about
being present it's the same premise so
the sporting world is teaching a lot of
um of aspects of of how to find that
zone and find that place
so we can influence at scale the
difference with the corporate world is
when we're leading leading folks is
we're leading at scale we're getting
others to do things that we cannot
physically do ourselves right and that's
the challenge and so if we're looking
back to the to the you know the really
the the foundation of what you're
talking about here it's the it's our
ability to intentionally be at peace
with ourselves be genuine be authentic
and and only when we're able to to
harness that we're able to then help
others and lead by examples
you know i'm looking at you know the
various people that may be listening
here including myself and the different
places where we are in life and
obviously none of us are 100 genuine 100
at peace with ourselves and it's a
constant struggle but how do i know
myself michael what i need to be even
working on how do i know to identify and
be first honest with myself where i'm
not being honest with myself
um
when we think of where we're putting our
energy energy is the one thing that we
have a finite amount of
and where we direct that energy are we
getting a return on that energy is that
energy impactful if we're thinking about
the same thing we have a problem we're
thinking about it you know our brain
loves habits that loves patterns it
loves
um processing things but it can be very
efficient inefficient because the
emotions get involved when our emotions
get involved we tend to kind of recycle
the same thought time and time again so
we may think of a problem or a situation
if their emotions attach with that we
can go into what we call a spiral and
that can take a lot of energy so we're
not solving anything we're just thinking
about the same thing time and time again
that's gross inefficiency and when we
allow those situations
come into our minds and again with
senior execs or leaders
they're quite lonely in a way because
they can't necessarily be sharing
everything you know what's happening
what their concerns or worries are with
people around them they're supposed to
lead people look up to them they're
bored um expects them to be solid
expects them to be clear-minded of
course they can ask for mentors and so
forth but a lot of it is in their heads
so you could imagine if somebody is
really festering on a
problem is festering in their minds
or they're spinning or they're not
getting into your blocks of place it's
incredibly wasteful and it also means
they it shuts their mind down to picking
up what's happening around them what the
reality is looking forward more
balancing their intuition
um with the data
and and distilling that down into you
know
being decisive where decisiveness is
necessary if you don't have enough
information understand what you're
missing how to get that but there's a
time where decisions have to be made as
well and that peace of mind
is so important particularly when
everything is moving fast
and that efficiency becomes uh dramatic
in terms of impact so it's not just
about us being authentic in general with
ourselves so that others want to be led
by us but it's also impacting our
ability to make good thoughtful
intentional decisions in the moment both
immediate that require decision making
but also other decisions that require us
to understand what pieces are we missing
and have that clarity of mind to and
have that peace to go and explore those
options to make it to make a good
decision vivian tell me a little bit
about climbing in the seven summits and
specifically mount everest how how does
that play into your coaching and and
your thinking process through what it
means to be it to be a good leader
everest is a great metaphor because it's
it's the obviously tallest man in the
world but it's incredibly technical and
detailed and there are so many
uncontrollable so i went there i was
super fit
i was i was strong i climbed hall
mountains before i was prepared
um
now at the same time i've always had a
fear of heights so there was something
in the back of my mind that was you know
definitely i was going in there anxious
but the ego was
was drive driven you've done tall
mountains before you know get put your
head down you'll figure it out and
you're good at grinding things out when
you're in when you're in tough positions
when i got there and two months on the
mountain so it's a massive 200 you can
imagine
two months and three rotations to get to
the summit of everest rotation one but
first of all you go by 10 days into base
camp to acclimatize
base camp is your base but that is 16
thousand feet that's about uh five
thousand seven hundred meters so it's
already very very high so you already
have issues of breathing the moment you
arrive at base camp and that improves
over time as you your blood uh red blood
cells propagate um but then it's
rotation one is where you go all the way
up the cumbers ball to camp one camp two
then all the way back to base camp uh
carrying supplies along the way
acclimatizing along the way dealing with
obstacles along the way then you wait a
week or ten days then you go all the way
up to camp one count two count three
more climatization moving supplies up
there then all the way back to camp one
or sorry base camp at that point that's
about five weeks in
your my body was emaciated most of us
were emaciated all our body your body
starts consuming muscle consuming all
the fat because you're not able to
digest at that altitude so then we go
down into the valley
a few thousand feet or like a thousand
meters or so for a few days and we eat
as much as we can we sleep as much as we
can recover our body to a degree back to
base camp open up our laptops and then
then the fun starts then it's really
thinking about weather patterns because
there's only about five to seven
days in a climbing season one can summit
everest where the jet stream moves back
from the summit and there's an ability
to attempt the summit and then we wait
and then if when the weather window is
there then we make the move for the
third rotation and third rotation is all
the way up through those same camps one
two three
four
and if we're lucky five is the summit
and then back down so it's a it's a it's
an incredible journey of obstacles of
things you can't control
and i think that's the
the whole take on this michael is that
that your your our egos break down
because the ego is of no use
when you're
hanging outside of everest at 8 000
meters
saying i can do it i can do it there's a
point where your body doesn't believe
that anymore and you know that
so you become very naked and very
exposed very quickly and the persona of
worrying about what other people think
of you that's irrelevant because
you're there with yourself you have a
few colleagues but everyone is there so
that idea of being extremely vulnerable
and recognizing what that feeling is to
be that exposed and the question then is
who are you in that position
and
those questions and the book
takes
is quite descriptive of the question in
my mind was why are you here
wow and that was a powerful question
that uh that needed answering at the
time
those
periods of time between the rotations
where you're sitting
you're acclimatizing your
you know you're in the process you're
not advancing you're in the middle
you're not advancing on an hourly or
daily basis and you know that you're in
sort of a waiting period when you've
come to conquer this feat what are those
days like what what are you thinking
what are you feeling
obviously also as a high paced executive
that is you know really usually going to
push things forward what happens when
you're sitting down and you have a few
days where you're like okay now i'm
recovering now i'm i'm waiting
yeah those days are actually bad days
because on the mountain the bad days are
days when you don't have things to do so
on those days we we go for a little
walks or we prepare our gear but their
days are reflection and days where you
really feel how tired you are you feel
you see your rib cage your your you know
how how emaciated you become
and in my experience those days about a
couple of weeks since the expedition i
got down actually for a few days
and it got down because what entered my
mind was wow i'm actually here and my
life is at risk and if something happens
to me i fall down a crevasse or or i
slip off and i sledge
and that's that's the end of me how will
people back there the people i care
about remember me and up to that point
i'd never really thought of that it was
too busy achieving i was driving it was
succeeding i was proving i was all the
time going forward with this huge level
of
doing more experiencing more
and at that for those days in the tent i
remember
thinking well will they remember me for
what i achieved or how i made them feel
and of course the answer was the former
it was what i would achieved not enough
of how i would have made them feel so
that was a profound um a wake-up call
for me and i came back to haunt me on
sunday where i really asked that
question you know um that's not how i
want to live my life because it won't be
meaningful to others which means what's
the whole purpose of what i'm doing if
i'm not going to be around what's the
purpose of being here right a legacy is
something you want you want to make the
world a better place to some degree with
people you care about that's fulfillment
doing it in the moment
and if something happened to me for them
to remember me because of that and they
could continue that
so this was me at 39 um 39 years old uh
facing these pretty pretty deep
uh life questions of
what's the meaning of life and who am i
and uh the pressure of everest was it's
so claustrophobic in a way because
there's no escape from that you can't
talk your way out of it your brain
doesn't believe it anymore you are
as i say very naked
and um
again go back to leadership and coaching
most leaders are are quite naked on the
inside they
and
very few of them ask for help and
there's this idea of failure a fear of
failure if i ask for help i might be
perceived as being weak
if i admit some of my you know
weaknesses that might be something that
that others will look down on or take
advantage of
and yes you don't have to share
everything with everybody but there's a
degree of of authenticity that comes
with
asking for help
and being human
and finding that balance as a leader is
it's it's that that's they're the
leaders to make a difference guys
richard branson
incredibly famous
global he mixes that idea of
um
he's good at what he does and he has
exceptional people around him completing
the circle
and he can be playful he can be profound
he can be curious he can be very driven
he can be all of those things but the
one thing that comes out of that is
an authenticity that inspires
followership and it's interesting i
think if you were to ask him along the
way how are you doing richard
um
his answer is i'm doing quite well he he
finds fulfillment in being himself
and an everest i found that that that
was so
that was the holy grail that i came down
the mountain with i just want to find
that space with me
and then other people around me will
probably benefit for that from that
but i've got to find it first
how does that translate into the daily
life so as we're progressing especially
in tech and you know the companies are
growing and and and you know putting
aside all the societal pressures and
we're looking at what's happening in me
with media and especially over the last
few years with the insane valuations and
the crazy expectations of delivering
value in unprecedented speeds in time
how how do we as leaders at that point
know to balance that and to maintain
this intentionality and maintain this
idea that at the end what we are we are
humans we are seeking fulfillment and if
we are fulfilled we'll actually be able
to bring back and do better for the
world because we'll make better
decisions and we'll be better humans
i think the the connection is very it's
very important for people not to get
caught up in the bubble
and to get caught up in their own bubble
in their own world so how to be grounded
how to have that connection with whether
it be customers whether it be society
whether it be
and and and having that intertwine that
where
one can be highly innovative one could
be pushing the boundaries one can be
you know
having
the greatest innovation ever that great
mindset and great culture but it has to
be connected also
with the world that we serve and and you
know on a on a tech side
with customers and and understanding
that how does one embroider into the
successful companies are the ones where
uh where the person the individual
using the service or or the app or
whatever it may be they feel connected
to that brand they feel as though that
brand there's there's a value in it
there's a connection there's a loyalty
there's a
those values are intertwined and i think
successful companies are the ones where
they can match that
exceptional
ingenuity innovation
with
a feeling of being connected
and being thoughtful about that and how
do you do that in your organization how
do you do that as a ceo um
how do you nurture that because it
doesn't happen on its own it has to be
thoughtful it has to be purposeful
and
again bring those two things together
and uh and that obviously it has
followership but it promotes a very
extremely healthy culture a culture
that's uh
that can be humble but extremely
ambitious and extremely driven
and that humility is a almost like you
become the lamp and not the moth the
moth is busy trying too hard too hard
too hard where people come to you
and that's an honesty of thought and
purpose
and there's a purity there that um
that the best leaders and the best
companies find and that's it's wonderful
to see because the meaningfulness comes
through it
so vivian i'm going on a walk in about
two hours and i'm gonna have about an
hour to to think and i was planning on
doing my
my usual routine listening to broadway
songs on on spotify and and not thinking
too much but but i do want to think and
i want to be intentional and i want to
challenge myself not on everest but here
on the boardwalk next to the beach what
are what are some questions that you
advise ceos that you work with or in
this situation me to
to think through
in that in that relatively short but but
important time that i'm going to be
reflecting for myself what should i be
asking myself and reflecting for myself
so that so that i can begin a process of
of being more intentional and being more
fulfilled
i i think the most valuable exercise
that i do for execs
is to get them to listen to what their
mind is saying listen to their inner
dialogue so we've about as humans about
we process about 60 to 70 000 thoughts a
day
98 of those would be the same thoughts
so our brain tends to repeat itself
again and again and again
and the emotions tend to drive a lot of
our decisions
um so if you were taking that um
that walk i would instead of you putting
more burdens on yourself okay here are
questions to think about here are things
i want so more processing more burdens
more things to do let me throw a few
more tasks onto michael's
as if his day isn't busy enough
will be to slow all that down
and just track
what are the what are the
things that are trying to invade your
mind almost like a conscious mindfulness
so when you go for that walk you're
listening to yourself what what does my
mind want to talk about right now do i
want to allow that to happen
to is that good for me is that burning
energy is that giving me energy
managing the energy level managing the
inner dialogue once we become aware of
our inner dialogue our brain almost
kicks in it's almost like we start
observing our mind
and then that mind starts to change
because it reacts it's almost like we've
pulled the tarpaulin off and awareness
starts to lighten us starts to free us
that's a bit like what happens to
therapy right we talk about things we
feel we'll feel better
um but we can do that in our own daily
daily lives just being consciously aware
of the noise machine in our head and
deciding
am i going to entertain that thought
does it give me energy or does it take
my energy away and just that one simple
question
being aware
is it giving me energy or am i losing
energy and making that conscious
decision
that's vivian
thank you so much this was inspiring and
uh fun and
and at the end it leaves me with uh with
a different way of thinking through my
day and and i'm definitely going to
change the way that i was expecting to
take that walk and i'll leave the the
earphone behind and i'm also going to
leave my tasks behind and and listen a
little bit more into what's coming in
and asking myself these questions
and thank you very very much for
everything and stay safe and stay
healthy vivian
you're welcome and great to talk to you
guys today again michael my pleasure
thank you bye
[Music]